okay these are my final chess games
of 2022
uh maybe I'll mix up openings a little
bit but we're starting with a London
opening
my reading is barely over 2500.
uh reading took a hit the other day in
the winter Marathon
so I have some rebuilding to do
maybe some New Year's resolutions to
achieve
okay I'll take it with Pawn
I like the start of this game oh I meant
to play Knight out of three not Queen F3
Arena 3 is a fine move though
maybe the queen bull Chill on G3 prepare
Bishop H6
we might see Queen B6
or Knight C5 wow
I'm very tempted to Castle here
maybe I'll play over T1 threatening
Knight C4
yeah this is a very typical setup for
London with pawn and E5
ready to attack
I'm Queen H5 incoming
uh yeah I think I can just take this
it could get a little bit tricky like
takes takes I don't think G5 works
though
like G5 I have Queen H5 is writing mate
yeah there's probably only time for what
less definitely less than 10 more games
2022 for me
okay I have to do something with the
Knight
this is actually kind of cool Knight D6
takes takes and then the pawns on D6
it's hard for black to play D5 because
Queen takes E5
and maybe before coming
[Music]
yeah welcome everyone who's like
overseas
is already
in uh already in the new year
okay B4 Knight A4
maybe bishop G3 first
ensuring that E5 doesn't hit the bishop
life is pretty good here
welcome to all the first time travelers
too oh let me move this
didn't realize I was covering the board
partially
[Music]
okay
hopefully that looks better
uh the bishop wants to come here
um
[Music]
how to do this before I hope we all get
stalemated in life when we feel like we
hit the bottom oh yes
uh
better to get still needed rather than
checkmated
okay yeah I wasn't stopping Bishop Z6
but bishop move maybe now before
and if Knight A4 I can take
like who's back
and get the queen out of trouble
threatening to trap the bishop
still threatening to trap the bishop
okay hitting the knights
I think some ideas of like E4
welcome back to
uh
uh lahi
solving for two months happy New Year
Mark valoy welcome back
foreign
[Music]
to try and break down the pawns maybe
rescue this Pawn in some way
maybe to play E5
I mean queen D7 is probably coming
or that okay now we can take
Queen H5 threatening mate
yeah if I can't defend I might as well
attack
shift attention to the king side
and I don't see how black effectively
defends H7 because F5 or G6 I just take
the pawn
no mercy
actually giving a little bit of Mercy I
forgot the Rook is hanging
but life is still good
hey welcome back Diamond Cutter Happy
New Year
okay now no mercy
okay nice start
uh top ten
I'm gonna try and stay clean this
tournament I want to finish the year
strong I want to start 2023 strong
this is a 90-minute tournament which
means
I mean in 54 minutes
it's a new year
so the tournament will go about half
hour into the new year for me
also for everyone just joining
um I do have the Charlotte command
uh my first in-person event in 2023 will
be in Charlotte's the second week
of January
and if you're watching in the future on
YouTube I'll probably end up putting
this whole thing on YouTube uh you
should definitely come to Charlotte's
Martin Luther King Day weekend
a big tournament Charlotte open
they're having a at least a few side
events too
I'll be doing game review and Blitz
Games with people and playing in the
blitz tournament
okay so I berserked
also just received 10 gifted subs thank
you to
Arla Desma
really appreciate that
yeah I really gotta watch my time here
don't want to get too low we have a
position which means very solid for both
sides
it could result in kind of a grinding
type game
finally grabbing space
I want to play E5 very soon
yeah generally this bishop doesn't like
staring at the pawn chain
um Play Bishop t7 Knight E4 I play
Knight D7
leaving the knights overlapping each
other
maybe this move
F4 would be a nice Square for the night
954 coming soon
this D3 G2
E2 even is a target
this move defends everything though
okay that doesn't defend E3
um probably worth taking the bishop
and then maybe my other Knight can
uh finish the unfinished business of the
previous night
yeah at this point I'm just trying to
simplify
I don't mind training all the Rooks
trade with me
a king can come in
and G6 F5
uh let's play this move
there's Knights
yeah this I'm not losing the bishop
oh the knights are going to be really
annoying though
check
is that premature
and they have been
I want to play D oh oops
oh no
oh no
I'm in trouble
oh no
foreign
I'm in less trouble but I'm still in a
lot of trouble
what is happening here
foreign
oops
I guess repeating allows me not to lose
okay what game
oh I was so close to flagging
yeah berserking was a big risk there
have to get it out of my muscle memory
nobody's working this game
except maybe I should maybe I should
if I want to win this tournament
and end the Year Strong
start the New Year Strong
I think berserking
I'd say the risk is worth the reward
we have a kind of reverse Queen's Gambit
exchange variation
white was trying to play a Kali system
foreign
Cambridge Springs
I don't think I mined the trade
the pawn is targeted
yeah so there's a few ideas here
and this is an idea
eventual expansion like E5
E5 actually looks really really nice
coming up
foreign
should I play the Stafford Gambit as a
beginner
um I mean at beginner level Stafford can
be a very effective opening if the
opponent
doesn't know how to deal with it
but I'd say it shouldn't be your main
opening like it's good to have an
alternative like something that's a bit
more solid
a bit more reputable that if the
opponent does know what they're doing
you're not gonna be lost out of the
opening
but if you play a lot of Blitz or bullet
then Stafford can be very very effective
okay like this position
um play this so now the queen is
overworked
trying to make some progress on the the
queen side
I'm very close to having a pawn Cube
Knight is very restricted by this Pawn
it's very common when the pawn is like
three squares away from the Knight
um does a good job restricting the
knights
okay this is kind of a pawn sack
let's see if he wants to take it
ooh
and take
it still takes work
foreign
of like funny mating ideas
maybe the queen queen can come in Target
the pawn
the problem is the queen is tied down to
the Fang in this Pawn
oh good move okay let's play this move
don't hurt me
foreign
okay don't mess with my Pawn snake
wait a minute wait just had this move
I have to be really careful
I think white could have maybe forced to
draw there
Queen z65 this move
not easy for white to defend the knights
move back idea Knight G3
okay
hitting the Rook
oh wow I didn't see that
hmm
no Queen trade
what is this position
so time scramble
hey it's a pawn Cube oh no my queen oh
yes my pongube
oh yes my time
okay
I couldn't resist playing G5 because I
think that's our Rosen drovey
okay uh back to tournaments
have to get as many rows and trophies as
possible before the end of the year
there we go
uh uh berserk again
playing Virgo power
playing D4 maybe I'll mix up the opening
depending what my opponent plays
we have D5 if I'm playing a Queen's
Gambit now
foreign
counter Gambit let's play this opening
this is like the counter counter gamut
wow
fascinating
a different type of pong Cube here
so I'm developing my Bishops before the
knights
um I don't want to give this bishop an
easy Square to move to
maybe I'll play this
so Bishop here I play F3
I'll try and get the bishop pair like
Bishop H5 I play net of four
there we go
queen wants to come in
thank you Abby Abby
stopping for the first time
yeah there's still a very small window
to sub
before the new year begins
so A3 preventing Knight B4
maybe I could have started with this
but A3 also prepares the eventual Pawn
B4
let's continue building up
yeah probably a rook wants to come to
the open e-file
complete Bishop F4
yeah there's about four and then Queen
G3
although then that allows Knight H5
I think you milk Stakes
and Nexus now
yeah this this Pawn Cube might last
forever
uh I really want to play D6
but that hangs upon
so let's play this
trying to optimize the pieces
also I got to move a lot quicker
let's see
like Queen H3 could be a nice Square for
the queen
wow
that's oh
oops I hung a queen
but my oppon's hesitating
[Music]
okay treating this as a sacrifice
uh don't hurt me
by 94.
Wahoo cheese
oh that was probably a mouse slip
um
oh
that was such a bad move
I'm in tons of trouble here
stop hurting me
ah okay
oh that was a rough game
I blundered a queen
um thankfully that's not my last game of
2022.
still got 40 minutes left
thank you rock flag and eagle
oh no my placing
okay
if it feels bad berserking
but I want to try and finish the Year
Strong
play C5
they have to be a little bit more
focused here
play a little bit faster and stronger
I'm going for F6
yeah this is a nice idea to play G5 H5
trades a bishop
I think you just call them
yeah I should be in pretty good shape to
attack
maybe yeah 92 Bishop D3 C4
before coming yeah
Bishop D6
the problem for white it's not easy to
attack the bishop we might see the sack
though
take take okay no sack
threatening G4
I was considering G4 and then take on
that one take on H2 I don't want to
trade off the bishop
now this is almost driving the queen
so close
okay the rook's ready to come in
maybe B5 first
maybe I shouldn't have played B5
but the queen is completely stuck
foreign
winning
thank you Samsonite
hey thank you for player chess Hello
Duck Master Eric and happy New Year
hello four player chess master
I probably should have taken the night
I mean this should still be really good
though
take
it's not so simple
rookie to the queen movie Queen F4
so Rook A7 King G6
King G6 anyway
yeah I have to trade in
I didn't want to trade
what's my plan
gonna go after the pawn
okay in game time
okay this should be very straightforward
foreign
hello
okay plenty of time
oh thank you I am Rosen van nice nice
username thank you to how to how
the prime sub
oops wait what I look away and I blunder
a rook but I'm still winning
yeah these pawns are unstoppable
okay plenty of time left
oh
generally three seconds isn't plenty of
time but when there's more than once
it's a lot of time
yeah happy almost New Year
thanks for all the hype welcome back
Snyder's Chumley thank you all right
thank you all the new people here
um
yeah I'm gonna I guess I'll try and win
the tournament playing against Carol
Khan
uh Bishop D3
yeah this is going to transpose into
some sort of French
I mean G4
the king H1 first
wow
eventually I want to play G4
thank you Soho checkmate
gifting to Jaffer Hassan
Okay g maybe H3 first
yeah I was waiting for black to Castle
now the attack should flow
I can gradually prepare F5 oh good move
yeah
um
let's play this maybe I'll still go for
F5 as a really key Pawn though
thank you
okay trading of the D5 hangs
I should have taken first
okay this is a massive threat
um
foreign
foreign
Happy New Year
oh dear what did I do
just hang a night
thank you
no I should resign
wow
[Music]
oh I had my chances that game
oh no
okay
those working
oh no my new year
um
I'm making a lot of uh a lot of just
careless blenders
but hopefully that can be fixed with
just a little bit more focused
a little bit more focused man
oh no my focus
I'm getting all the blunders out of my
system
before the new year begins
okay I like this position because
there's a lot of attacking potential
like Knight H4
Bishop H3 is already playable
oh it's not so simple though because
King wait
I have G6 take and then G6
I'll come back my life as a lawyer
I don't think I want a queen trade
keeping my queen
it's a good move
control each file
threatening Queen H2 Maybe
G5
oh wow
okay I have to be really careful here
thank you Samsonite
foreign
decision
[Music]
allowing Queen D7 but then
in King fa Queen F5 King G8
Queen G6 we trade
yeah this is still very much a fight
if I play King oh wow
okay that was a nice gift
okay I was not expecting the game to end
so quickly there
I'll take it though 12 points
leader has 21. a leader cleanly berserk
winning every game
uh playing Pico FIFA
okay gotta get one last staffer Gambit
of 2022
this could be the last effort of 2022.
let me try and make a count
that's probably the most common Stafford
position after Knight C3
only choosing what to play White falling
for one of the main traps
yeah this is already very very pleasant
for black
I used to play Queen G5
um I think Queen G5
still playable let's go for H5 first
preparing Bishop G4 and I'm preventing
light from casting either way
and the problem with White's position
there's no drugs for a bishop so I'm
just dominating all the dark squares
and the queen might swing over to A5
cause some havoc on the queen side
ooh yeah that's a free Pawn
wow more free Pawns
so many New Year presents
oh there's a funny line there's a really
funny line Rook B1 Bishop D4 Rook B7 and
then Bishop B6 threatening Queen side
castling trapping The Rook
oh no my Pawn
White's probably not going to take the
pawn
oh that's disappointing
a free night though
okay not so disappointing
oh
uh I really want a castle
but castling is like not that great
yeah this is just better
check
King H4 may be coming
Chuck
Chuck
oh there's a funny line
Chuck
Dole why why do you have to do that
Chuck
I know it's made in one but
I wanted to castle with meat
Chuck
go this way
yes
Chuck
let's go
counseling to attack the rook and also
checkmate
I know I'm not supposed to play with my
food
but the food was so tasty there
I couldn't help myself New Year Bitties
oh thanks for the biddies thank you Gary
put that towards the pizza fund
thank you my wife is a lawyer
so much hype that was such a fun game
staffer Gambit leads to Queen side
counseling with checkmates
also led to missed made in one multiple
times but
let's not uh pay attention to that
playing Miss Dobby
uh this is like um Harry Potter
was Dobby Dobby was probably married
maybe trying to think
Dobby was like the gremlin creature
right
okay
attacking
via the diagonal
C6 I don't think I've encountered C6
before
um like usually people play Knights C6
or D5
I guess C6 is playable
thank you sandswall
oh we do not call house elves Gremlins
sorry to seems sorry if I offended
anyone
okay
not sure if I have a thread along this
diagonal
but the prospect of hitting G2 looks
very appetizing
let's go for Bishop D3
so I've taken away box costing rights
I'm also tying down the Knight to the
offending this Pawn
I'll keep complete development
um restricting Knight B4
maybe some idea of E5
E5 we trade
box in the queen side Castle
it's a happy position still resembles
some London
with the queen on G3
I'll take and try and open the D file
okay now The Bishop's a Target the
Queen's the Target and the knight's
still a Target
and The Rook could even be a Target like
this is probably a threat
um but maybe I can be a little bit more
subtle
I gotta move quicker though
maybe this
so hitting wait what's Happening Here
a lot of things are attacking each other
take
I think I'm winning the exchange
ooh
A2 is kind of hanging
okay
allowing Bishop E4
King A1
and Bishop C2 Rook D4 wow
it's kind of scary but I think I'm
squirreling away out of this
and I want to play Knight C1 and be safe
Safety First
okay pinning the knights
maybe C4
this first
wow
fancy
they gotta move a lot quicker
no mercy
now chasing moving away from defending
z7
okay I was close good game
of the tricky opening
a lot fought back even after losing
material
okay
trying to find my rhythm here
another London
um
let's play this
I was trying to set up this Knight B5
trap
but I actually like the resulting
position
like this nylon H5 can create a lot of
how cool attacking possibilities
hey Happy New Year
oh we're 20 minutes away from New Year
in the central time zone
I think you agronach
um
might as well go for H4
not holding back
like King F1
rookie one
foreign
looking for ways to break through here
I think there's almost something but
um
[Music]
maybe this and then G4
it's risky it feels so wrong to
like violate my Pawn chain
they're not violated but
disturb the harmony of my Pawns
but I'm also trying to disturb the
defenses of Black's position
um
okay let's start with this
no
let's play this
because black doesn't have the option of
preventing the trade
so essentially the G file is guaranteed
to open
and then if takes I can take with queen
or Knight or Rooker Pawn I'll take with
Queen
pressure is mounting
if Knight's E7 I have 95
.
okay now G7 or Knight F6 coming
again I have six is a very feel good
move
because of this I take in Fork
and if this I taken Fork
and if this was made in one
got no mercy here
UB data it's May
so I'm threading the g-pawn
if G5 I am Busan
uh let's play this
going for the double up
and essentially I'm up a full Queen
okay now if I take
uh tricky
okay the Queen's gonna try and
find another entry point
I don't want to allow F4 though
I might just end up winning this game on
time
okay
this is pretty smooth game
fifth place
Five Points out of first
this person
on a very clean streak I might play this
prison next actually
is it International master or I am Rosen
uh yeah it's both as a double meaning
uh no berserking let's try and like just
not oh okay I'll berserk
if the opponent berserks I'm inclined to
berserk pack
so we have a London
uh this lion calls for Queen B6
H5
this is still all opening prep
there's a strong line here okay not
quite happening
and Bishop D6
should I probably won the queen side
Castle
and White's a just a bit short on space
new Trading
make some gradual improvements
turning the up on
yeah I do appreciate like all the new
year wishes and chats
uh thanks everyone
sometimes during these intense games I
can't really look much at chat
but I appreciate people tuning in
such a special day
uh let's play this move
Bishop might find its way to a different
diagonal
okay I had to give in even though I
weakened the D4 Square
I don't want the Knight to come to D4
how do I stop it
Bishop there there there
'll play no
just play this
I want to lift The Rook
okay if I'd sack and then let's just do
it
that's better work
it looks working Chuck
and meat
okay that worked
trying to get my way back to 2500 in
third place tied for first
tie breaks maybe aren't the best because
I've lost some games but
uh fighting back playing luisi knob is
working
kind of try and
finish cleanly and strongly
foreign
I should throw in some e4s as well
I like the sign though
this is like a reverse version of the
previous game except this time we're
trading Queens
I'll go for this plan Knight D2 Knight
B3 Knight A5
oh thank you my wife is a lawyer
I'm gifting
supporting more
I'm pretty sure this is like very strong
I've looked at similar positions where
white just accepts the pawn here
and the idea is to put the Knight on C5
but how to do this maybe Knight E5 Happy
New Year from the Netherlands lyric
happy New Year mjz man
maybe at some point in 2023 I'll make it
back to Netherlands
a very nice country
wow okay let's play this move
preventing 94
F6 might be coming
I can play this first
what a cool position
yeah the pawn is just actually really
fine there and if H6 I take and take on
E6
we might see Bishop C2 but then Rook H2
okay so now I have a cool Pawn chain
I haven't lost a pawn yet
also I hear fireworks in the distance
people celebrating early
look at these Pawns
I still have Ollie pawns a couple sets
of double Pawns
um
wow King D2 Bishop D3
some really fun games to finish off a
year here
ah
start with this
okay pawns are probably about to come
off the board unless we see takes takes
an F5
wait I can take on
wait
and take a few different things
I should take here
so now the Knight is in Black's crib
oh that's a good move though
ah
what have I done I have this move though
maybe it's okay
and King will walk up a little bit to F5
what is happening
the position seems so delicate
but also so strong
sounds like a muscular flower
so takes takes takes takes
and it's a showdown
okay it's La Fong Happy New Year lafong
what time zone are you in happy 2023
already
uh I have to move the Knight oh I could
take no uh
maybe I could let's just play this
yeah we have the countdown timer it's 11
50 am for me
soon to be 1151 or no 11 51 11 50 P.M
it's clearly past my bedtime
[Music]
okay I want to take and then win this
Pawn
wow
just put the Rooks behind the Pawns
maybe I should have taken
but no time to regret anything
yeah this is such a dominant position
uh let's play this
and that
restricting the Knight
um look at this
oh that didn't work
oops
after a resort to time
it's still not a bad position like
there's compensation for the pawn
but maybe it could be better
could be worse
there we go Rook see it I have Knight p7
oh no my Pawn
opponents saw the main threat
yeah The Rook is tied down to defending
C6
how to do this
I'm queening
and winning on time
okay that was a fun game
I had some really fun games to stream we
had like a pawn Cube win there's a
castle Queen side with mate from a
staffer gamut
there is that game
can we get one more standard
the final the maybe maybe the final
maybe not the final
and there's only seven minutes left of
2022 for me
this is a staffer declined
it's already slightly better for black
because I have one extra piece developed
again 94
94 is a very ambitious way of playing
and it sets up F5
I'm not quite in first yeah I'm still
not even top three
playing the person in second place
you should time it to on passant mate
right after midnight or right at
midnight
uh that would be difficult but
see if
can pull some miracle like that
I think I can just play Queen D6 here
chucking the Paw in Rook B8
Queen A6
there's almost a funny line where
like take or night before
I hear all Castle greenside
so guaranteeing a shark game here
oh this could be my last full game of
2022
and we'll see
my next game will probably start in 2022
and then finish in 2023
. yeah white can't play B4 because
Knight two lights proving me wrong
uh yeah that's one free pawn and
probably another Free Pawn
I mean it could be some trades
but in the very end like here it takes
takes takes I have Knight C2
oh there's that move
I take with Queen
and there's a three
let's just move back
Knight B4 is a threat
yeah pretty risk-free position
you might still trying to attack
taking a small risk here but A5 should
come
um okay that plungers a piece let's play
this
I have to be careful
Queen C6 I have this
I have to be really careful
take
it should all be okay
um if I take on D2
that's a very very tricky move
in King C8
hmm
there's Rook D6
this is Bishop E8 Bishop E8
it's a funny move but it keeps the
diagonal defended so it prevents uh
triple pork
white was threatening the very dangerous
pork using the pin and the fork
oh really it's white still goes for that
I can take
Bishop B4
breaking the PIN
and what this move does it threatens the
queen
because the Pawn's no longer pinned but
it also adds another tigers and Knight
of course obstructing The Rook
oh three minutes
okay this game's gonna finish and then
I'll get one more game starting before
the new year
yeah I found the countdown on some
random website so I don't know if it's
gonna make any sound
so we'll find out shortly
lots of fireworks in the distance people
probably can't hear it on stream though
okay let's not blunder
foreign
[Music]
check
where's my meat
there we go okay
okay
next scheme
this
I mean that was probably my final full
game of 2022.
I berserk now let's not bizarre playing
the top up top seed
this is going to be a very Monumental
game regardless
I'll play a little bit offbeat though
playing for an A5 A4 in the first five
moves the idea is actually to play Pawn
E3
90 seconds left
uh can I play Pawn A3 maybe I should
start with
should start with this
wow
hmm
Bishop A6 doesn't quite work
I don't know what to do let's play this
in Castle
okay now now special A6 still doesn't
work
I guess Bishop B7
uh what to do
45 seconds
and this game is going to span one whole
year
that's how time works right
I don't want to lose this game this is
basically like my first result of the
New Year 20 seconds
here we go don't hurt me
don't you dare 10 seconds happy New Year
Black Goose
things for the New Year's bits
oh wow opponent really wants to hurt me
two one
Happy New Year
yeah sadly I couldn't time it with any
on plus phone checkmates
but that happened a few weeks ago hey
it's Irene thanks Irene gifting 10
. appreciate that
well I hope an ad didn't just play there
that would be so cruel
maybe for the YouTube audience I'll like
I'll put a mineral ad
right before
the countdown finishes
wait why is the countdown still going
oh it's um it's counting into the new
year
also I'm in big big trouble here
um
even though I told my opponent not to
hurt me
foreign
take I think I should play this move
there's also F6 but
okay let me remove the countdown because
I don't want to confuse people
okay played F6
going for Knight takes D4
um
foreign
how to do this
you work here threatening this
I feel like this game is going to set
the tone for my whole year I feel so
much pressure
I think you blew water or something a
Year's worth of watching your videos
with Adblock on
oh thanks so much
I still want to play D4
oh wow
uh
uh I don't care about the Apon or maybe
I do
like this
white king is going to open up a little
bit
oh this is gonna get really really sharp
but hopefully shark in my favor
and queen e3 coming
three
check
that's actually kind of terrifying
I want to draw
foreign
foreign
foreign
oh what a dirty start to 2023
oh man
I wasn't expecting the year to start
in such a dirty fashion
oh happy New Year Eric Happy New Year
we're dirty New Year
I'm putting on my heart rate monitor
because I should have
I should have been tracking my heart
rate
that was
I'm still shaking from that
oh dear
oh
okay
let me uh let me try and mentally
recover
so I'm undefeated in 2023
and we're starting this is my first like
real opening of 2023 ponziani time
here we go
also thank you Neil welcome back
I think you Clockwork dingo
oh no my Pawn if takes it's a funny trap
okay here we're having very very solid
position
[Music]
I mean
I feel like after that last game I need
I need to play some solid chess
recuperate
um I don't really want to trade
team bishopath one
I'm being extra solid
at five wow
okay now it's time to trade
because I think what's going to happen
is Vlog is going to be left with a ISO E
Pawn
and maybe I can win some material
the queen
I don't even need that like Knight C4
yeah offering the queen trade also
threatening the pawn
playing very positionally here
I don't want this whole year to be full
of dirtiness
I would appreciate a little bit of
cleanliness
thank you jpp
yeah thank you everyone in chat for
tuning in
witnessing such a
historic uh
I don't know this feels historic
Moment In Time
can I take if I take there's Rook D2
I'll play 93.
just massage the the weak Pawns
yeah very soon
1965
and these light squares
okay they're having the bishop
play F3
and now you can find a happy place on G4
then rookie 4 and King E2
and the bishop can't touch any of these
things
foreign
how to like make effective progress
maybe that involves like trying to
create weaknesses on the queen side
um I don't want to trade Bishop for
Knight
there's a plan of
um taking and then getting the Knight to
D5 never mind
maybe Knight G3 coming
oh
this is not so easy to win
let's go back
how do I do this
and typically family-friendly
International chess master Reddick Rose
and we have the dirtiest and most nasty
New Year's Eve my God that was filthy
I'm sorry I love it you're welcome from
Liverpool
of uh
I don't know what to do here I feel like
I'm getting outplayed
I'm gonna put the Knight on C1 I guess
that's just not a good Square though
I'm in trouble here
foreign
[Music]
okay
this is something
oh no not this again
foreign
Flags to start the new year I feel so
bad
but I guess I could feel worse if I lost
those games
okay it was working again back over 2500
undefeated still in 2023
let me try and play cleanly
that's all I want for Christmas Even
though it's past Christmas
I played this opponent earlier
no that was a different game though but
we had the same position earlier
this is actually a really funny position
yeah Knight C5 Knight E5
this looks familiar
I'm gonna take a long shower after
the Stream
oh such funny Pawns
uh let's play play this first
nearly two years wow happy 2023 Eric
happy 2023
Destroyer
appreciate that
you have to be really careful here
actually not sure what's happening I
might be worse again
oh no my position
[Music]
play B3 and then Rook F1
okay H4
wow
there's a really funny idea to walk in
with the King
it's a really cool end game
because this Pawn is so strong
if B6 I play Rook A1 this Pawn is weak
so I don't think this game is gonna be
as dirty as the previous games
oh we're defending this Pawn
ensuring that this move can be played
safely
you know those pawns I don't think I
care much about but maybe I'll play I'll
play this for a good measure
wow
King is just chilling on E7
oh dear
oh no
another dirty fagging coming
foreign
I'm not even like trying for dirty Flags
we're just kind of happening naturally
what is this
I'm gonna have to take a long shower for
maybe most of this year
well I'm in first place
still undefeated
is this gonna be my first Stafford
Gambit no first King's Gambit first
Faulkner counter gown as of 2023.
here we go
I Bishop B4 a little feel-good move
pinning getting ready to Castle
now threatening this and this and this
not easy for white to cover all the
threats here
that's a move though I think I have to
play this
defending defending also aligning
not defending but
yeah there's no way white can take on G7
okay now
[Music]
can I play Bishop C5
and get away with it
I really want to but
I think I should Castle first hey it's
just Dojo what's up chest dojo
hope you had a good New Year's stream
Happy New Year
if you're just joining I'm undefeated
for 2023
but all my games this year have involved
dirty Flags
uh maybe C6
I should develop first
yeah let's practice good principles
maybe threatening Bishop Z5
idea 94
foreign
five almost working
[ __ ] about five first
okay now C5
D5 looks
it looks kind of risky actually
maybe I'll play like Rook d8
it's a fancy move
threatening the pong
so it takes I take the pawn and pin and
win the queen
uh maybe now C5
because if I win the queen queen C3 I
win the queen
I think I just trapped the queen
wow no the queen has A1
well my opponent find it that's such a
funny Square
almost a blind spot
uh
is now check
and then take
hmm
fast bits of the new year
also the fireworks are crazy yeah
how many people are like in the central
time us
now 12 18 a.m the new year was already
18 minutes ago wow
time flies when you're dirty flagging
got North Texas
our Ledesma Central Time
such a funny position
so I'm trying to just exploit The King
The King gonna come up to C4 wow
I mean
can I just sack
take and then take and then take
crazy thing is I don't know if I'm
winning
like where's my win
Queen B7 check
we'll see if I win
are you listen F6
okay Queen B3 I have C4
so yeah white can't force a queen trade
now I'm ready to take hitting the queen
okay this is my cleanest game of 20.
23.
and this is also like just really dirty
like
what happened in this game
that's such a mess
by Bishop A1 for the giggles
yeah the bishop and pawn formed this
wall so the king can't really do much
I'll put Wayans looks wrong somehow
if I'm tied for it first no guarantee to
win the tournament though
um but I'm on a nice streak
as a person oh that person might be
winning but might not be
might be flagging actually wow D2 nice
move
Anna safri coming in clutch
or the game
playing the Prince Seven
here we go
okay I'm just trying to be clean here
I'm gonna go for a different type of
setup
it's like a hybrid of London and um like
Mainline Queens Pawn opening
interesting
so F5 is clearly the idea
you can play like Queen C2 and Bishop D3
A3
Queen side castling here
I go for G4 eventually
think about going for G4 I have to make
sure there's no problems with the
diagonal
foreign might be coming at some point
black clearly wants to play E5
yeah I can't easily start it
so I think I just have to allow it
um can I take this
looks like I can
I can take the Knight
take here
okay I think that worked out I am
defending the oh I'm losing F2 though
this is it
there's still some compensation for lack
um that's still a kind of annoying move
I mean maybe this move
just neutralize the file
not the easiest position
[Music]
can take a knight D4
F3
restricting the bishop
this bishop is really out of play
maybe it can come to G1 and
some E4 move
it does prevent rookie five
just kind of nice
um can I get away with E4
I think it's better to play this first
so if takes I take with a rook
oh
okay I think black missed an opportunity
there
still not easy
in this move
eyeing some Queen C6
rookie two
so slightly terrifying
to get this move
trying to calculate take six Bishops
before it takes takes
Rook D2
there is some
Bishop G5
maybe it's okay
I do have 92
even if Rook B6 I think I still played
like some night move
which night move maybe Knight B5
oh wow
I didn't see that coming
in a little bit of trouble here
I think it's still okay I have some
Pawns
King's not getting muted
I want to take only four maybe
oh B2 hangs probably misses it
A4 is still attacked
I don't need to take it
okay going after A4
can't really be defended
five I play Rook C4
[Music]
and this could be the last game that
counts for the tournament
messy game
okay let's play this
foreign
Knight G3
okay powerful kingside Forks to finish
that game I was in trouble that game
keeping the undefeated streak
at least for the year not for the
tournament though
playing a doctor lagunov
and yeah this is
almost certainly going to be the last
game I'll play E4
got the carocon never played this upon
before
two
I think some D4 move is called for
E5 with some points
I think the bishop is a little bit
misplaced
threading G7
question is how to do this
in Bishop E3
some F4 coming
yeah the Knight is a bit misplaced Paul
wants to play C5
I wonder if I can know B4 Knight F5
thank you
maybe Knights
A4 ambitious move
discouraging C5
the B5 may be Knight C5 anyway
okay G4 may be coming
I mean now b4a3
[Music]
very closed position
and B6 could come but B6 hangs upon
and queen B7 it gets messy still
I think things are like a lot more
controlled in this game than than some
previous games
again Happy New Year to everyone
[Music]
appreciate the thousand plus viewers
tuning in
on such a day
I just want to go for A5 like clamp town
oh okay let's play A5 first and then
I think I'll eventually transfer to the
king side
like I can combine Bishop G4 and queen
E1
and I should maybe win the pawn at some
points maybe not though there's Queen d8
oh but then I take take and take
so that could take take and then Queen
here
okay
oh do I have allow over G8
what's happening I've worked off two I
also have G3
and this first
hey it's Jeffrey Zhang
happy New Year Jeffrey Jean
the tournament's going to end in three
seconds well opponent hang made in one
no opponent doesn't hang me than one
uh
okay well
I think I won the tournament
if you're just joining uh this is
a tournament that started for me in 2022
it's finishing and what's now 2023
and this is a final game
shout out to Jeffrey hope you had a good
stream
I tuned into Jeffrey's stream
like hours ago I was participating in
the words on stream
okay there's a request to join the party
I saw Jeffrey was interviewing I think
it was uh tanjong Yi
seemed like a really cool interview
almost as cool as what this trackmate is
going to be
okay
was I threatening mates
it's threatening to win The Rook
there we go
I had some very questful games probably
should have had several more losses
but the undefeated streak stays alive
for 2023. great start to 2023. thank you
Empire of Ohio games
I appreciate that gained a little bit of
reading this tournament
thank you Arla Desma
so anyway I'm gonna put this whole thing
on YouTube so if you're watching in the
future on YouTube uh thanks so much for
watching let me know in the comments
what your
2023 chess New Year resolution is if you
have like a New Year's resolution for
chess
um I'm not even sure what mine is
maybe it's to not lose a game
given such a start to the year
also if you're watching in the future on
YouTube
um
I'm gonna be making an appearance in an
over the board event in Charlotte we
have the twitch chat command
uh but I'll also leave links in the
YouTube description with more
information it's taking place in a
couple weeks Martin Luther King Day
weekend it's a Charlotte open and it
should be really cool I won't be playing
the main event but I'll be doing game
review with people and Blitz Games and Q
a and I'll be playing the blitz side
event as well
so stay tuned for that
and stay tuned for more content too
a lot of content in the pipeline for
this year